your first animation film yes was it
everything you expected to be it wasn't
really fun it was really fun it was I
mean I am such a fan of Disney Pixar
everything and particularly this
franchise the car sir I mean from 11
years ago when I saw the first car
people always say like did you do this
movie because you have kids I'm like no
I did this movie good I'm Yours I love
this move I mean it's great to also do
something that my kids can watch which
they cannot watch scandal so it is fun
but but I am really proud to be a part
of this film in particular you know
there's a great message to a to you
asking about your kids I have two girls
as well and ask the idea of having a
mentor yeah
who's your mentor I have a few mentors
you know obviously doing the Proximus
film has had me thinking about that I
mean Shonda Rhimes is a big mentor for
me she's my boss and my friend and I
really look up to her as a professional
but also as a mom and as a condition of
this country I think she's pretty badass
and awesome my dad also I've been
thinking about him a lot because a lot
of what this film is about for me is
that Cruz learns to dream big to not be
afraid of big dreams and my dad is
somebody who taught me to have big
vision to have a big imagination and to
dream so I'm really grateful to him for
this interesting shade up is one of the
best lines is don't fear failure be
afraid of not having a chance that's
right so what was the biggest risk you
took in your career oh gosh I feel like
as an artist you have to be willing to
take risks all the time I think all of
us have to be willing to take risks all
the time you know - like there's a
social scientist I really love Rene
Brown who talks about you know being in
the ring beautiful in life no matter
what that means whether that means like
telling a guy you like that you liked
him or asking more rays or writing that
book you've been thinking about whatever
it means but to be in the ring in life
to be in in the stadium in the fight you
know taking risks and living boldly that
that is the point you go for it I try I
try I try to encourage myself to to be
daring and cruise as a trainer yeah you
ever had a trainer like her I don't know
but I love her she's so inspiring and I
love I love the idea you know also in
their friendship that sometimes she's
there for him and sometimes he's there
for her and I think that is also one of
the messages of the film like I love
that it's not about like a girl beating
a boy about like people coming together
coming together with people that don't
necessarily look like you were act like
you were they're not from where you're
from but you will win better when you
make room on your team for people that
aren't like oh my gosh I love that